thank you
Sovereign
pillars of Islam and what are the six
pillars of Iman doesn't matter it
doesn't matter the pillars are
um yeah it's um
yeah for Muslims what you have to do in
order to be a good Muslim and and uh all
types of pillars the most important or
the six pillars of faith in Islamic
Creed the most important
um
all the six pillars of faith according
to the Islamic don't care you don't care
I don't care what some Muslims do inside
Islam Don't Be Afraid what to do my
response I'm saying to you now calm down
calm down calm down it's just a break
I'm reminding you that when you are
finished watching the video huh
is that you click the link below and
donate now
are claiming to know about the religion
of Islam which is a religion that
followed by according to Pew more than
1.8 billion people that's not relevant
let me just finish my comment I'm saying
that you claim to know what Islam as a
religion said you're not a theologian I
ask you a very basic question that any
child in any murderer would know excuse
me I ask you what is the six pillars of
Islamic Creed and you couldn't even
offer me an answer and now you're going
into Hadith and what the Quran says this
is way above your pay grade why do you
think you as an unqualified Uncle uh
person that's seeking job Seekers
allowance whatever you're doing as a
jobless man have the right to speak
about Islam
where do I work or whether I ever have
okay
why do you think you're credible to talk
about the religion of Islam because
Islam and you don't know the basics I
know the basics what are the six pillars
of creed Islam is so easy that the
desert Arab understands okay
illiterate and understand so you say you
understand it but you don't know what
the six pillars of krita which is
understanding because I've I've read
I'm asking you now you're saying that
I've read the Sira which is the
biography the prophet I'm asking you
what is the man's name and you can't
even tell me your surname I don't care
you don't care oh you don't know maybe
but you said you know about all the
verses in the Quran which talks about
fighting so selective knowledge
I travel this far to do is to distract
the discussion from I can assure you
I've come here foreign
let's just summarize where we are so far
I asked you what you meant by War you
said defense that's what you said you
said I want to go to all the Muslims
that are defending ourselves by using
okay no problem we'll come back to that
then we ask you some questions some
trivial questions we asked you what are
the six pillars of Islamic Creed you had
no answer what is that you said I've
read the series
generator you don't dare to
talk about this I'm coming to you I'll
come to you yeah but I'm just
summarizing Where We Are that's all I'm
doing you don't have to get triggered
and get upset and shaken all these signs
and talk it's where I was in front of
children in front of young people
there's a child behind you why are you
swearing in front of the child huh I'll
ask you no question no honestly how am I
supposed to know it's a child I don't
know either look it's a you're
okay talking about okay fine no problem
no it's it's a problem no it's a problem
you could come here I'm honestly
discussing number one what kind of
number of countries okay oh yes okay no
problem and what happens to the numbers
that's relevant are you afraid for me to
speak and engage with you I'm saying to
this number one we've established you
don't know what the six pillars of
Islamic Creed are the five pillars of
Islamic faith
you're afraid we have established that
you said that you you said that you know
what Muhammad was but then you haven't
even known what the full man's name is
now let me ask you a question
Speak oh he got so angry
all the time
what
university did you graduate from doesn't
matter it doesn't matter
[Applause]
more fluids about Universal Oxford
um about the Quran than you do you want
me to show you that it's not relevant
it's so easy this
Islam as a tool to occupy invade and
occupy the whole planet for Allah's
cause you'll never get this in your life
in the Quran University of what
so these kinds of intellectual
Expeditions this kind of intellectual
activism couldn't be done
wouldn't be done without your charitable
donations because this is an integral
aspect of the dawah that we challenge
those kinds of views that we're seeing
in the Western World which makes
International media now we have a chance
to respond
Islam net has established an entire
Center
doing the work educating people of Islam
crushing islamophobia are we going to be
the people we are a junction now as a
community are we going to be the people
who are going to
contribute to this course
what are we going to be stingy Allah
says in the Quran
uh
um
foreign
[Music]
Allah says in the Quran that you people
you people have been called to given the
sake of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
give charity in the sake of Allah
so amongst you will be those who will be
stingy
and whoever is stingy miserly
he's only being stingy upon his own self
and Allah is the rich one the one free
of need and you and me you Allah says
are the poor ones
and if you turn away yes
Allah will replace us replace me in you
replace you Allah says with the people
other than you and they will not be like
you
what do you think
so add something else yeah okay
yeah right
yeah
so the best way to prove to yourself
and to Allah that you are not among the
stingy ones the miserly ones the weak
ones
is that you give in the sake of Allah
you have an opportunity the link is
below just click it what's going to take
10 seconds of your time 15 20 seconds
you wouldn't even use that kind of time
to blow your nose on a handkerchief
the time is now
click the link